sam Amick the NBA senior writer at the
athletic covering the NBA in his most
recent column why the Clippers grand
plan landing Leonard and Durant is still
in place Sam kind enough to join us let
me start there do you think that's what
Jerry West has cooking here with the
Clippers good morning Dan I mean yes the
answer the short answer is yes that
longer answer is that I was pretty
surprised after you know the some of the
recent moves in New York with porzingis
going to Dallas and and the Intel all
around the NBA being that the next feel
very good about their chances of getting
durant to here that the Clippers are not
waving the white flag they this is not
the only plan in place but you know
their number one plan a is still there
and they feel like they have you know a
competitive edge on the Knicks
specifically and others when it comes to
their top to bottom presentation Steve
Ballmer is a you know you know his
background you're talking about a former
Microsoft CEO and far and away the
richest guy in the NBA and they're going
to try to paint a picture 1 July rolls
around that compels you know somebody
like Kevin to come there will hang so
that's a bias Harris trade had a lot to
do with that and then also filling up
the cupboard with a whole bunch of
graphics at all so anything that puts
them and play for other situations as
well why do we assume that Kevin Durant
is not going back to Golden State I mean
I'm pretty close to that team on a
regular basis and I think the answer
there is just it's been very very
uncomfortable all year long and the
irony of these past couple of days with
his infamous press conferences you know
the Australians that he has had is that
I keep thinking about the fact that you
know draymond Green has got to be
sitting there in the background with a
little bit of a smile on his face like
now I told you all this is going to be a
problem you don't be a distraction and
you know because back in you know the
early regular season when they have that
dust-up in the Clippers game you know as
you know that was the root of it all
that was the fuel on the fire was the
idea from draymond standpoint at Kevin's
and
since on signing one-year deals you know
and this narrative that was gonna dog
him all year long was going to be a
distraction so I'm not ready to say it's
a hundred percent by any means because
you cannot predict what a man's gonna
feel especially when he goes down maybe
wins a third straight championship you
know but you know the Intel right now is
certainly pointing him out of town yeah
I thought that from the beginning Sam
that that he had kind of done what he
wanted to do got a couple of titles and
then you know he got the the blowback
that you ruined basketball he's not
gonna join LeBron he doesn't want to
help LeBron's legacy he thinks he's the
best player in the game and if you can
revitalize the garden you know that's
you know that that's where you put a
stamp on your legacy that's pretty
impressive and and he's such a sensitive
guy but try to like if you can't handle
the media in San Francisco I mean he
goes to New York oh my god yeah I mean
yeah I'm with you I mean listen I will
say that the media and the bay the the
tricky part about how he got frustrated
the other night is I really do think
that on most days his story gets totaled
extremely accurately and fairly and
deeply if that makes sense
and he's a New York situation like from
a psychological aspect you know and I
know they're guys like Kevin it drives
them nuts when we end up trying to read
their minds and that I think is part of
his frustration but you look at New York
and my thing would be that yeah if you
go win a championship out there or even
have a lot of success you're going to be
a you know they're gonna build a statue
of you eventually but if you don't you
know the the other scenario the other
possibility is pretty disastrous you're
going to be miserable and they're going
to it's going to be Carmelo 2.0 and that
is why I think then Lipper's are looking
at and again saying okay if maybe that
is a little too hot for you and you want
a different speed where here's the other
narrative come steal la from LeBron on
the back end of his career with the you
know with the organization that has such
a battered brand for all these decades
of losing and dysfunction and if you're
that guy who kind of flips the script
then maybe that is more your speed and
these are all the things that he'll be
chewing on
July who's running the Lakers LeBron or
magic you know what's crazy
it's it's really not LeBron and I
actually kind of want to write some more
about this soon
it's magic and it's genie and they they
have kept LeBron and his group not an
arm's distance by any means but they
have not kind of capitulated on every
single thing they wanted of this season
and I think the Anthony Davis thing
bears that out because obviously I think
if rich Paul was the GM then you know
obviously LeBron engagement and also
Anthony Davis's agent then you know they
would have found a way to get a deal
done now they couldn't control the way
that New Orleans handled the situation I
understand that but even the coaching
stuff some of that stuff is real when it
comes to and I'm not gonna see from
LeBron but people around him certainly
not if you having the highest view of
Walden but sure here you know he's still
the coach just last night Rob pálinka
said he was doing an amazing job so
they've tried to kind of keep a little
bit of a distance between the front
office and their franchise center piece
but it is tricky and you know I don't
know where it's all going this is maybe
a longer conversation but I really think
after them missing out on ad you know
there is a scenario here if I was LeBron
where I'd be pretty seriously concerned
going to get that second start is if you
play out all the scenarios I can't find
one right now that really points in the
Lakers favor yeah we've seen this
scenario we've seen this script before
where LeBron comes to town changes
coaches and then gets rid of players so
none of these Laker players can be I
don't think surprised by it they might
be disappointed but they should have
read the script that's been written a
couple of times here and I'm with you I
think I think Luke is on numbered days
here and and you know these younger
players as well you know they realized
that their time is probably short but
wait what's the pelicans game plan now
over the next you know three four or
five months I mean they are first and
foremost I think Dell danced their GM
Mickey Loomis
and you know this part yeah he's the
Saints - yeah but he also technically
speaking oversees the basketball
operations group for the pelicans they
guarantee a-- are now just hoping and
praying that Danny Ainge and Celtics
meant you know everything they said
during these past couple weeks because
the way I was told is that and this is a
pretty unique situation because the
Celtics couldn't trade for Anthony right
now they can't until July because of the
stipulation in the CBA until Kyrie
Irving is a free agent they couldn't
touch a B they had to have these
informal talks where you kind of set the
stage for more talks this summer and
give indications about what sort of
package might be available for you at
that time and you know I was told that
Jason Tatum's name was definitely
discussed and not promised by any means
but discussed and so if you're the
pelicans I think that is the best
package but you cannot predict nobody is
more cunning than Danny Ainge
and so I think you know now the question
becomes you know what does Danny
actually put on the table in late June
you know when you're talking about this
thing for real so the Boston's front and
center you probably revisit the Lakers
thing at that point the Clippers are
going to put a package out in front of
New Orleans and the draft lottery comes
into play here big time as well because
the Knicks probably more than anybody
are hoping they can get that number one
pick and if they did you know and the
odds are not great its 14% then you know
they'd be in that ad game too so it's
uncomfortable in New Orleans right now
but I think this is why there was a
major advantage to waiting until this
summer the best rumor that you heard
that didn't come through probably Mike
Conley to Indiana he wanted to go east I
can't blame them the poor guy has just
played all-star caliber level basketball
for his entire career but he's in the
West and this is the land of Steph Curry
and James Harden Russell Westbrook and
Chris Paul and so I know Mike has pushed
back on this idea publicly but it did
certainly seem like there were pretty
strong indications given to the
Grizzlies that he wanted to play in the
East and so the Pacers thing
like a real possibility I was told that
it got pretty far down the road and they
just couldn't get it over the finish
line and that would have been one where
you know we continued to overlook
Indiana I mean they're right there with
the best of the best in the East and
Victor Oladipo being on the shelves you
know Mike to come in there and I think
that a little bit of a savior I think
that would have been a great fit but
they just couldn't get it done Sam great
stuff always great to talk to you we
appreciate your time thank you
likewise Dan thank you Sam a m'q the NBA
senior writer and the athletic for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show ass
[Music]